most of us can think of at least one
person we may have helped a little
or maybe a lot in our lifetime but what
if that list is so long you might not
remember them
at all that's our next remarkable woman
karen eddington as sheri swens shows us
karen changed many lives by offering her
home as a rest stop
when they had lost their way on life's
journey
for most of our youth there was someone
we barely knew living at our house free
of charge
whether it was a mother and her children
escaping abuse
a troubled kid who had been kicked out
with a family of five whose home was
burned by an arsonist
our mother karen eddington always seemed
to find those
in need of refuge for many women being a
wife
a busy mom to four growing boys while
having a career and volunteering on the
side
would be a very full life but karen
eddington makes room in her heart
and home to keep giving as you know all
of us have struggles in our in our lives
and
and sometimes we just need somebody to
help us through those periods of
struggle
karen has been that somebody for a long
list of friends
neighbors and even strangers making them
feel
part of the eddington family when they
needed family most
we just wanted them to have a soft place
to land and to get on their feet
and to do what they needed to to do to
be successful
like a former employee of cairns who was
on the brink of being homeless
and her husband had gone to jail and she
was raising two young kids and just
was at her wit's end had no resources
they stayed for months no rent no
grocery bills
and no judgment and likewise for all of
those who would come and go in the years
to follow
they pitched in on household chores and
focused on getting their lives back on
track to be out on their own again
the eddingtons adapted to each new
situation
not knowing when or who might move in
next
sometimes it was just a mom decision you
know and they all
went along with it my boys and husband
were very patient
and and also charitable to
you know put up with the comings and
goings and modifying their lives and
helping out in their ways it was a blur
but i don't i don't remember feeling
burdened at all by having other people
in our home
you know just it was like more siblings
except
they're more like on the friend scale
than sibling
all the while karen and husband gary
were busy raising their boys
involved in their church the pta boy
scouts
and taking family vacations karen has
stumbled over some hurdles of her own
losing her gift basket business when the
economy tanked in 2008
and recovering from gambling addiction
in overcoming that i do think i've
become
a better person because i'm more
empathetic
sympathetic i understand better
that people need second chances and
they need a leg up when the next door
neighbor's home was damaged in a fire
karen invited them in for a drink of
water
and told them to stay until the house
was rebuilt
another spontaneous offer of help that
made a lasting difference in someone's
life
you know we were glad to be able to do
that for them and we still stay in touch
with
all the people that have come and gone
out of our home and
and they all are much more successful
and stable than they were in that period
of time
now watching their sons grow up to have
families of their own
karen knows they see the good in making
room in your life
for others i'm super grateful that she
set that example for us because
um it has certainly influenced our
choices to
to give back and and to look outside of
ourselves
and that's why karen eddington is our
remarkable woman
sheri swensk 8 news now